اعلنت قوات فاجنر الروسيه عن سيطرتها على
نحو 40% من مدينه مخموت مشيره الى ان
القوات الروسيه تواصل قصف اي امدادات يمكن
ان تدخل عبر الطريق السريعه الى القوه
الاوكرانيه وقال قائد تلك القوات ان مدينه
مخموت مطوقه من ثلاث جبهات لتضييق الخناق
على القوات الاوكرانيه لكنه حذر من ان
التاخر في وصول الذخيره لقوته قد يمنح
القوات الاوكرانيه القدره على صدد الهجوم
اذا انسحبت شركه فان الجبهه ستنهار
باكملها فاجنر متراصه ويمكنها سحب الجيش
الاوكراني وتدميره مع عدم السماح لهم
بالتركيز على اجزاء اخرى من خط المواجهه
ايضا نحن نتقدم الى الامام ويجب على
الاخرين اتباعنا باي طريقه لحفظ ماء الوجه
ما يعني اعاده التعلم ويمكننا القيام بذلك
من المهم كسر الصوره النمطيه المقاتلون
يسال ونني لماذا التاخير في امدادات
الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو وايضا لماذا
لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر جدد
من جهاته قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه اتفق
مع القاده العسكريين على استمرار عمليه
الدفاع عن مخموت وخلال اجتماع مع كبار
القاده العسكريين بحث زينسكي ملف توزيع
الاسلحه والمعدات بحسب العمليات على
الجبهات
اما وزير الدفاع الامريكي فاعتبر ان قيمه
مخموت هي رمزيه اكثر من كونها استراتيجيه
واشار الى ان سقوطها لا يعني ان روسيا
غيرت مجريات الحرب لصالحها او تراجع
اوكرانيا واضاف انه لا يمكنه التوقع حاليا
الى اي مدى ستصمد ضخموت امام الضربات
الروسيه
معنى لمتابعه اخر التطورات زميل رائد
الاغبر اهلا بك يا رائد ما اخر التطورات
في مخموت حتى الان خاصه بعد الانباء عن
سيطرت قوات باجنر وبالتالي روسيا على
اربعين في المئه من هذه المدينه
مساء الخير محمد
يعني قوات فاجنر اضافت بانها قتلت حوالي
عشرين الف مقاتل بينما قالت سلطات دانيت
كونا بان في المدينه محاصر حوالي عشره
الاف مقاتل ليس لهم طريق للخروج الا عبر
طريق شاسوفار السريع وهذا الطريق تحت
نيران المدفعيه الروسيه بالفعل هناك حديث
عن سيطره قوات فاغنر على المحاور الثلاثه
ما عدا المحور الغربي بينما الجانب الاخر
الاوكراني يؤكد بانه
لديه طرق اخرى طرق فرعيه بالقرب من مدينه
قسنطينه في الجهه الغربيه ايضا عدا عن
الطريق السريع لدى تشيسوبيار مدينه
تشاسوفيار مدينه او عفوا بلده خرونفا في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه ما زالت تحاول
قوات فاجنر اقتحامها حتى الان ولم تفلح
هناك مقاومه عنيفه من قبل الاجانب
الاوكراني وحتى يفقيني برجوج نفسه تحدث عن
ان
يعني ان المقاومه الاوكرانيه كبيره وليست
سهله وهو يرسل توابيت من جثث المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين وصفهم بالشجعان انا ارسل لكم
المقاتلين الذين قاتلوا ببساله وشجاعه
لكنهم ماتوا ايضا هناك مساله اخرى النزاع
والصراع ما بين الدفاع الروسيه
حول امكانيه امداد مزيد من الاسلحه قال
بريكوجن بان يعني جزء من الاسلحه وصله
الذي طلبه لكن اجزاء اخرى لم تصل من
الذخيره التي هو يحتاجها
الاربعين في المئه التي سيطرت عليها
فاجنرمادا اهميه هذه المنطقه استراتيجيا
بخموت بشكل عام والبناطق التي سيطرت عليه
هيرون او عليها روسيا حتى الان
هنا يجدر اشاره الى ان التباين يعني
تقييم اهميه هذه المدينه ما بين الغرب
والاوكرانيين والجانب الروسي بالفعل الغرب
يشير الى ان هذه المدينه ليست بذات
الاهميه لكنها مساله رمزيه صمود القوات
الاوكرانيه من انسحاب بينما ترى روسيا
والسلطات هنا في دانياس كان هذه المدينه
هي البوابه للمدن الكبرى مدن كراماتورس
قسطنطين اوفكا
التي تحجز او تحبس مياه نهر سفر سكيدانيه
عن المقاطعه المقاطعه بدون مياه كل ثلاثه
ايام تضخ ساعتين فقط مساء المياه هنا
يحتاجون للمياه فلذلك مدينه سلافيان خلفه
باخ ملط هي اهم المدن التي تحتاج روسيا
للوصول اليها من اجل ضخ المياه لان روسيا
تعمل على ضخ مياه من مدينه رستوف في
الحدود الروسيه وفتح قنوات لايصالها الى
دانياسك لو تمكنت من الوصول الى صلابيانس
لاوقفت العمل على القنوات التي تعمل على
فتحه لايصال المياه الى مقاطعه دمباس
وخاصه هنا في دانيت
محمد هناك محور المعارك ولكن سريعا رائد
مدعم بقيه التطورات
يعني في زياره لوزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه
استمرت ليومين زار عده مناطق اهمها افديف
كمارين كانوا في مخالفه اليوم كان في
مريوبل بالفعل معارك ضارة تجري في هذه
المناطق الا ان مريوبل كان يشرف فيها على
تطور اعمال البناء واصلاح المدينه بعد
المعارك
التي كانت ولكن يبقى التركيز على مخموط
كما قال زميلنا رائد الاغبر من دوناتك
[موسيقى]